you are an adventurous woman you're also
a thrifty woman I was told recently that
you like to use the uber which we all
have to use uber but you use the least
expensive uber is that right well first
of all of course that's good I mean I'm
just
but there's one there's an uber where
what's it called well now I know it's
called uber pool okay but what happened
was of course I choose the least
expensive option I mean I'm not an idiot
yeah and I was this was a couple months
ago and I was trying to over home from
somewhere in Hollywood I didn't drive
and I it said uber pool and it was right
when that came out and I didn't realize
what it was I just thought like it was a
cute summer reference and so I pressed
it and then I got in the car and I'm
just like enjoying my ride home and then
we pull over and somebody else gets in
and I was so freaked out and I
immediately start texting my friends and
live tweeting it yeah if you find my
body the last people I was seen with and
I was giving descriptions and I was and
then of over the course of the carpool I
realized that I had just hit the carpool
wait my question is what is your
perspective what about their perspective
they're just getting a carpool to work
and Kristen Bell is sitting in there you
know nobody nobody cared that he didn't
he had other things to worry about he
had to get somewhere that's why he
called the over okay
you